the breaking news that malaysian police
have uh confirmed
uh that the unclothed body of an irish
teenager who went missing
10 days ago has been identified by
her parents as nora quarian
was here with us
it was a heartbreaking journey for them
going to the hospital where
i think they had in their hearts the
awful knowledge that the body that had
been found a little bit earlier on today
was that of nora
and it's now being confirmed that when
they got to the hospital
um they went to identify the body and
they've confirmed that the body is
indeed
nora and that's according to muhammad
matt youssef who's
the police chief for the area where the
holiday resort where the family was
staying
is now nora went missing has been
missing since the 4th
of august this huge search has been
underway over the last 10 days to try
and find her her family always believed
she'd been abducted they said it was
totally out of character she'd never
wander off alone but
the police on the ground in malaysia
said they found a window open in the
cottage in the resort and they thought
that she had just walked off
as i say hundreds of people have been
involved in the search from
volunteers to train trackers as well
looking for nora
she's vulnerable we know she has severe
learning difficulties and
today around lunchtime we saw forensic
teams an ambulance heading into the
forest
close to the resort and her body indeed
found just a mile away from her bedroom
next to a small stream in a very dense
area of forest we're told and
in the last few moments as i say we've
heard the family has now confirmed that
the body
is that of their daughter nora yeah i
just had a statement from the
lucy blackmon trust who have been
supporting the family throughout saying
the trust can confirm with great sadness
that the body found today is that of
missing teenager
nor korean local police have confirmed
identification
the charity will update as soon as
possible please respect the family and
do not approach them
at this difficult time all at the lucy
blackmon trust our thinking of the
family and continue to support them
as they come to terms with this news
family had only just arrived haven't
they on resort
they have they got there on the third of
august this is the start of a two-week
holiday
it's a beautiful little part of malaysia
just seven little bungalows nestled
amongst this tropical rainforest
apparently according to reports nora
very much looking forward to this
special holiday
and now her family are facing these
hideous questions these very difficult
questions as to
how their daughter died and how long
she'd been there as well given that she
went missing 10 days ago now okay thank
you